it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gon keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when he was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do
[Music]
this is really the fighter in the kit
we're out come on baby
yeah we're good chin
chin guts on the old school roots of
fight uh fire and kid collab there you
go bro i have
30 boxes in size medium of the red uh
biker jacket and sweats can i have a
jacket that you wear a medium oh crap
it's only immediately why don't we get
one i don't know why they only have we
should a lot of these only mediums
though yeah but a lot of people would
want them i don't know if our fan base
is a medium there's a reason they sent
me all mediums those are what didn't
sell you know oh
oh and also daddy has a track on fire
kit 3d
our boy p
fighter and kid 3d coming out well we'll
see we'll see hopefully well
my plan is if we do get it we'd release
i think there's like 12 episodes or 10.
all i know is my buddy my buddy lane
norton phd
food scientist posted a thing on
asparagus and how everything you've read
about asparagus like it's horseshit like
it's not bad for you i mean if you and
the doses that it is it doesn't cause
all the things i thought it caused
there's all kinds of science so once i
read that i went let me try a diet coke
right i was traveling nothing bad
it was delicious and i now i'm drinking
diet coke [__] off i mean it's the one
thing i require in the studio
if i don't have my dc's i'm going to hit
somebody i'm like trump he drinks a lot
of diet coke yeah you know he had a
button and
obama had a button and it would be like
for emergencies obama had like he wanted
green juice no no obama's button was
like steve murchie get in here and trump
was like very cool so that buttons me
use when every time i hit it you bring
me a diet coke they said he'd go through
like 12 to 14 diet cokes a day
and then trump had a hilarious tweet he
said and he got so much [__] for it this
i think this is before his present he
goes uh
he goes isn't it funny only fat people
drink diet coke
you know i'm reading a book called this
will not pass these two journalists
um
who sounds depressed about what what
trump is like for like they did
literally thousands of interviews
republicans democrats mostly republicans
and the big secret is trump runs he was
running he ran his administration like a
mafia don so if you [__] were a
republican and you said some [__] shady
[__] yeah yeah like just to the press it
was just against the agenda no no no he
you'd get word he'd be like trump is
pissed at you he's gonna campaign
against you he can't kill you but he'll
you're not getting reelected
so he'll guy he's a terrible candidate
and he'd go so then these republicans
would have to go to his office
and literally grab him one guy goes one
guy goes what do i do gotta get a grovel
and and his advisor goes well
yeah yeah you do so he'd have to go
there and go mr president you're right
and it's just it's you know it was
really it's a narcissist i was really
close
you know
you know who knew him really well i had
a direct line to him and talks to talk
to him all the time guy named gavin
newsom
why
well because kim kimberly guilfoyle his
ex-wife dates trump's oldest son oh
interesting okay so also they had a lot
of and oh guess who guess who
contributed to gavin newsom's campaign
back in the day donald trump yeah
trump is a democrat
so so and and gavin newsom owns plum
jack wines you know he's got a lot of
business on things
and they they go through what happened
with the corona thing
where the virus comes in yeah and trump
was like trump was like we got this
[__] yacht with all these people or
this boat this cruise we got to keep
them off the coast what do we do with
them it was all nobody knew what the
[__] was going on with covet nobody knew
even trump was like yeah we got to be
careful with this [__]
but and then then newsome was getting
people from all different angles so like
when you read it you kind of get you go
oh when you're the governor i get how
it's like you have the biggest economy
in america mr mr governor you got
[__] everybody giving you different
kinds of advice but mainly people were
like this is a real thing we don't know
how to deal with it we don't know what
it's going to turn into so newsom was
like i guess we shut it down and the
governor's like we i guess we should but
it was all haphazard you made an excuse
for getting some right now i'm just
making excuses i'm thinking she's one
government invite you on this one i
understand you give him too much credit
you even said you're gonna slap me
around yeah it was especially defend
newsome i will straight up no slap
i'm going to take this and ball it up
really you know what that is daddy
that's a fist
you defend news some i'll fight crawfish
guarded dude it's the only thing i'll
fight over is newsome i understand he's
the worst in the world right i
understand hey my favorite part of
newsom is he's like i'm banning all
flights to any place that bans uh you
know is against gay rights blah blah
blah and then
in california people like okay so that
means no montana no blah blah blah and
then where's he at right now
he's in montana with his family well so
so here's the thing with with what you
when you read about newsom or any
governor
you you okay hold on hold on i told you
you defend them hold on hold on maybe
i'm gonna throw you out of the [__]
what they do is newsome newsom is a guy
who goes oh
it looks like the tides have changed the
winds have changed are with the woke
crowd in the beginning
let me let me jump on this bandwagon
still like that right he's still let me
let me jump on this yeah he's still like
that
problem is all of a sudden that [__]
becomes a major political liability
amazing he's double down on because now
because now he has hopes and aspirations
run for the president united states so
now he's going at desantis yeah and was
like if you want freedom listen this his
whole campaign was right now is if you
want freedom hey florida
come live in a free state freedom come
to california okay you guys are being
suppressed we on our all rights here
it's like sir sir you're the one that
shut us down like north korea and ruin
small businesses now look at all the
economies and all the red states
booming well
all the democrats
and then he's going to say but we're
we're pro-choice so it's it's it's going
to be this battleground thing you know
with states it's going to be interesting
to see what happens uh yeah forget all
this news
what do you uh i haven't seen in a while
i feel like uh i've been uh daddy went
to where first uh daddy was in new york
daddy went to new york to watch his 14
year old daughter act in a play now
couple things you fly to new york that's
a lot of fun cheap too
then this is a father's love for his
daughter then i borrow our boy dove
davidoff's car
i get in that car still have the
challenger or no no he's got the uh
porsche cayenne
or the porsche mekong
or the mekong the little suv yeah
and uh it's okay yeah and um you're
better than that dove yep i get in that
york makes sense though that's true so
now i and i by the way i'm i'm on
mulberry street where dove lives i call
our boy sammy the bull gravano i go
sammy i go first of all you're a star
people love you on the podcast and i'm
like and and oh by the way you know
everybody's talking about you i mean you
know you're doing megan kelly next
you're like a star i want my ten percent
i go i go i go i'm in front of the raven
i club which i was i go it's not even
the raven i club anymore you know and he
goes yeah well tell everybody i say hi
you know i go yeah i go listen though
bottom line is here's the bottom line
this is a little weird i need my ten
percent
and he goes because i mean i kind of i
kind of i kind of launched you into this
yeah you made them and he goes you're
right you're right all right you know
and but you got to wet my beak a little
bit too and i go i want your beak yeah
that's a quick breakfast because that's
good here's a problem though i got a big
beak i go what do you mean i got i go i
go what do you like
i'm a pelican
he's so [__] funny he's so funny well
people don't realize when when sammy
came here he was with mark and brennan i
don't know if you remember this but he's
standing there there's kind of a pause
in the conversation and he goes
now am i wrestling them both at the same
time
he's got a silly he's a personality yeah
he uh
now my thing is is because i was talking
to schultzy yesterday about it and i
told schulte hey he's not my boy or
anything but i think
freaking uh sammy the bull on flagrant
would crush dude you should consider
hamon it would be so big
and with their the way they do things
it'd be a killer show now i was thinking
can sammy go back to new york he can
he's got to talk to us does he want to
talk to his um
uh i i think he maybe can't i i don't
know if he wants to i i that's where i
was out with it because obviously that's
i i did so we're we we're taking we shot
a best dub with him yeah and it's going
to be broken up into two episodes we got
that much footage i take him to dinner
um we're in the car talking it was
[__] wild i got all this stuff and so
i think i mentioned to him something
about new york and i think he said
something like no
i don't want to go back you know i get
it like i was thinking either he can't
go back uh a he can't go back because a
variety of reasons right the old
stomping grounds might be
the mafia is still currently there yeah
so there's that so the risk to reward
there i don't think he's not afraid and
then c
is just the memories like he's probably
a bad vibe for him you know i asked him
all that i don't think he
i don't think he minds that stuff like
he was there still a sad time for him
you know he can't do flagrant uh if you
want i'll talk i'll put him in touch
with andrew because i think yeah that
type of show he's cutting his special
right now so he's like let me get out of
this and that's a great idea i'm cutting
my special we need to talk yep i got you
down 40 minutes i'm very happy with it
so you went to new york you went to the
playbook were you out of town before
then or no why is that i feel like so so
i get to new york
then this is a lot of fun i got to take
a car up to the catskills where my
daughter's in theater camp and that took
a whole camp yeah it's only two hours
away but oh i forgot there's new york
traffic so it takes you two hours to get
out of the city did you take the train
aren't you from trump there's no train
up there bubba you can't get there no
and so i drove all the way up to our cat
skills and i'm doing that for kids
whatever i have to she was in cinderella
she crushed it was she cinderella she
was the she was the mother of the king
of the prince and so it's a pretty big
part it's a whole broadway playback what
if you're like she was gus gus just the
fat mouse well some of those some of
those kids those new york kids who've
been born since they were
five well it's like they can sing do you
watch stranger things
uh yes the new season so let's finish it
and i can ruin it there's a scene in
there
where um one of the characters is
playing like he's trying to get all the
demons to go for him so his friends can
get work done and he's playing um
uh puppet master by metallica bro
it has to be one of the greatest saints
ever shot really it is so lit why it's
so good why it should that just you know
boom boom boom boom boom and then these
are how about when i did it yesterday so
yesterday
it's like 11 30 at night i should be
writing and instead i'm on youtube and i
get i see ariana grande
singing rihanna
shakira she's doing covers of everybody
goes dude check it out she can see she's
got the greatest voice i've ever heard
in my life her impressions are
interesting she's on another level yeah
so you just found this brendon and i go
brandon
like that i said i go watch this bad
[__] and i just get
you're bored huh
i'm 39. i said brian i'm not gonna watch
this ariana grande very familiar with
her like i was like you're super bored
and she doesn't they'll do like the
jimmy kimmel like um or jimmy uh fallon
like
wheel of the game
this person's singing that and like
she's saying she's i will always love
you that the [__] whitney yeah she's
so she's a mom well i talked to a bunch
of broadway big-time broadway uh singers
and they said they said there's no
question that ariana grande puts all of
us to shame and i was like what you know
that i didn't know that i don't know
she's um
a monster yeah welcome to
2014. well
that kind of super stardom is not an
accent is it no it's not an accident
she's an outlier she's a monster
but the reason i brought strange things
because one of the girls on there i
didn't know this i was like god she's
such a good actress her dad is ethan
hawk her mom is uh the girl from kill
bill what's wrong with her thurman um
yeah so those are her parents okay so
she grew up i think she's so good and
then i was like who is she and then i
was like last name's uh hawk and i was
like oh there she is it's my hawk yeah
she's so good in it well there you go
yeah i mean when your dad said you know
you know you know you know you know you
know nothing hawk and your mom's i was
watching ethan hawk on
stage i was she's gorgeous i was
watching i knew uma i went to high
school with her but i i i
watched
the husband
really yes i did in new york yeah she'd
know in massachusetts oh wow she she
dated my buddy marty
and uh she was always a really cool
down-to-earth human is she retired did
she just get out of the biz i think it
became hard to work
i think it's well she had all the
opportunity i think too she was like i'm
over it like uh cameron diaz a lot of
them was like no i'm over it like
cameron diaz is just like i'm out
millions do you want to take you know
well yeah there's a lot of things i
think it becomes harder and harder to
hustle and and harder harder to get the
jobs you want
you get to a certain age as a woman and
it becomes weird what a career yeah i
mean like a very small handful of women
work into their 60s she was the first
person i remember heard the first
ever movie she did was les on don
jarrett which was
dangerous liaisons was john malkovich
and she took her shirt off in that and
the entire country and when i say the
entire country and this girl i went to
high school jacked up have never they've
never seen they'd never seen tits like
that nobody knew they were like what
really and that made her a star and i'm
not joking no one's everybody talked
about her dude hurts her and pulp
fiction she was great and her dad her
dad's a buddhism a professor i think at
columbia she grew up very very in an
intellectual 511 oh she's a big girl
even taller than that i think
oh star and even hawk aren't uh together
anymore no
but i have three kiddos though but she's
imagining your dad's ethan hawk he's
just making all those horror movies left
and right and then your mom's um thurman
she's also married to gary oldman so the
kid was around gary oldman as well
monster actors
jesus christ i grew up watching ethan
hawk on stage he had a theater company
called malapart and i used to submit my
plays to them and i used to watch those
guys and they they would they had just a
great team he's fantastic he's great
down to earth wonderful really i'm a fan
i used to always celebrate i used to
talk to him about it sometimes i'd see
him on the street i was a young actor
too and yeah celebrating
things you uh you missed uh the fight
companion sir you're a mess i'm going to
stop missing those let me tell you why
they're fun i get jealous i get sad your
boy luke rockhold was on there uh he was
on all the shrooms right so he was on
all the shrooms and at first when he was
talking it was a little slurred speech i
was like ct is a [__] yeah and i
realize he's on shrimp that's all it is
because he was 20 minutes late which is
fine he was like um he texted me goes
hey man i'll be about 20 minutes late
went for a run took shrooms i
lost track kept running i was like okay
no doubt then he gets there he's kind of
like you know not drunk but you know how
did like slurring your words a little
bit i was like what is happening here
yeah in my head i was like god [__]
ct man because you know he's flopped
forever and knockouts the yawn knockout
but no he's fine he's never been in
better shape he's amazing he looks like
he's fighting holocaust hungry and
dangerous yeah he was great on there
great insight yeah luke is fantastic but
hey luke don't be doing shrooms on the
companion or do
or do whatever you want because nobody's
gonna tell you my favorite was trevor
wallace is on then he knows nothing
because being him we do spots just
rambling like at improv and laugh actor
we're both trevor wallace yeah he's
great he got huge off youtube huge off
the white claws thing like uh yeah the
white claw bit he had on there so he's
massive on there but he's he was stand
up forever he didn't understand like
nine years he's funny great but so we're
regulars at the laughing improv but
where they always book us together i
gotta start doing so me and him are
together all the time and then i was
trying to think of companion i forgot it
was uh july fourth weekend you know mark
just could not wait to get this up
mark's like real quick get this up just
let's uh look at this
look how shredded luke is
yeah luke is a different [__]
to him uh i'm not mad at luke luke looks
so now he's a ralph lauren model i would
say mark looks pretty comparable dime
piece wise sure but look at luke's back
extremely low body fat like that's like
legit that's so [__] he's a mark
luke's a freak he's a freak you guys
both look good that guy that guy will
he's good at wrestling and uh grappling
phenomenal fighting
phenomenal his fight against paulo costa
i'm excited dude he looks like a [__]
he looks like a hungry dog i thought he
was going to start crying when he was
talking about how he's going to win this
fight i was like he's about crying he
just you can tell he wants it so bad i
know god i hope the best i've not seen
i've not seen this kind of dog in him
man remember oh you missed the stretch
when i first met him was a couple days
before he fought chris wyden and took
the belt
and he was so confident dude i was just
like jesus yeah i think people confuse
his confidence for cockiness and that's
why he gets a lot of hate off he's
clearly gets hate too because he's
[__] everybody's wife and girl wants
to [__] he's good looking so there's
that
dude he was talking about the ralph
lauren contract i was like did like did
you make money after he's like oh seven
figures dude oh yeah throughout florence
oh yeah man's only fans oh he does yeah
and i was like oh you're like cooking
like morning breakfast with your nuts
hanging out the front he's like no i
don't show anything they just cook and
train and they pay me 50 jesus to post
stuff on there beautiful
he's he's uh he's [__] my remember
when
my wife at the time with her friends
met we were at a club a bar and he shows
up with tariq and some of our other boys
yeah i mean you those other guys could
be [__] they're mutants next to them
well it doesn't matter who you are it
doesn't matter who you show up with you
could be on fire and they're not gonna
notice that you're on fire yeah they're
not gonna piss he's got a polo shirt
tucked in with like
slacks and like cool kids he always
looks cool and his blue [__] eyes and
his hair back and my my i've never seen
my wife my wife my wife went like this
just
she went like this she goes she saw him
she goes i don't know where she goes oh
he's cute yes oh he is cute and she
turned her friends and they all went
wow
no he's [__] handsome [__] well you
want to you want to breed with him
yeah you know you want to suck his [__]
right there in the bar if you're those
ladies
i don't know man i mean
take it easy on my ass i mean
you suck them though hey hey
don't say stuff like that it's the
mother of my children i know but it's
luke she was just looking at him said he
was cute bro
hey hey hey she's suckling hey no no
don't don't say that stuff you could i
mean it's luke rockhold
i get it i mean you and i would
anyone if my girls i want to suck them
like half at it man i mean what are you
going to do suck them
suck it
you know don't say that suck it it's too
aggressive is it yeah
yeah suck it
oh
shocking he has a tough fight against uh
paulo costa i think he gets it done bro
i'll tell you what dude i'm getting
ready for this thick mudder august 27th
mark is going to be there
why is your skin glowing dude i thought
you'd never ask
i gotta get ready because i'm i'm glad
daddy's grinding i'm big
and i'm on carnivore daddy's back on
carnivore right had a little bit of how
do you get your fruits and vegetables
dude how do you get your fiber how do
you get probiotics how do you get
prebiotics multivitamin all that stuff
bro you would and you you think i'm just
taking
just heads of lettuce and broccoli and
shoving in my snack the blood of the
animal or something no tap it's very
dude bro one tasty scoop of ag-1
contains 75 vitamins minerals whole food
source ingredients multivine multi
mineral probiotic green superfood blend
and so much more it's delicious what
does ag stand for dude
that's a great question athletics
athletic greens athletic green and i
forgot for a second there because i
thought it was a trick question it's
athletic greens one contains 75 vitamins
and minerals dude eight ounces of water
i put in tastes fantastic all right they
we love it you guys love it moms love it
dad love it it's for all you guys
join the movement brian i need i need
vitamin d dude so that's the problem all
right i need a well i need a free
one-year supply hold on it's ag-1 hold
on hi ag-1 yeah you'll do that wow
that's very generous what um can i say
that right now all right yeah but i
wanna
supporting free one year supply vitamin
d right and five travel packs for free
with your first purchase if you visit
athletic greens.com fighter today all
you got to do go to athletic greens.com
fighter take control of your health and
give a.g one a try damn
speaking of fights i had a little bonus
to pick with you what do you got
well
i'm very high on a guy named and i know
i'm a newcomer pereira no you're casual
no no no i'm not i'm i'm afraid you're
as casual as it gets no i'm really not
that's that's hilarious you would say
that now i watched every one of the
fights
um i want to talk volkanovsky for a
second now i'm assuming listen to the
shop show cause this is why you're
coming out i saw a little clip about
about
you going battle around the boy
on them didn't go about them but you
were like this is almost a guy
which is hilarious yeah now i gotta i
gotta i got i i believe the tie the top
seven will beat him now here's here's
what i do agree with
you don't want to dethrone your
greatness
in some ways your most colorful champion
ufc the most i mean israel asanya you
want that guy checks all boxes at the
top yes for forever so you're gonna
you're gonna fast track a guy can not
speak english and only strike
he's just a bad matchup now you keep
saying only strike and i need you to i
need to understand a couple things dude
he is in glover to share his camp now
it's up in connecticut i understand i
don't care but glover to share
all he does this kid is wrestle for the
past two years oh it doesn't matter
i have trouble keeping this guy down and
he doesn't have trouble keeping anybody
hey hey we know that's wrong though yeah
right you know this right he's his coach
right yeah so you think he's gonna be
like yeah he does struggle on the ground
let's see he's his coach he's buddy this
kid is so strong and i think he's going
to be on the street
not with the high level guys whitaker
oh
whitaker's going to get knocked out if
he tries to stamina oh right now so now
he's left with one thing
oh and you don't he's got to wrestle
with him and you right oh this is gonna
wrestle with him yeah do you know
whitaker's wrestling
background yeah i know whitaker's on the
national team you know he was going to
be on the national team but ufc went we
need you to focus on mma anymore but i
can be on the
national team and compete in the
olympics for australia and dana went
let's just focus on fighting sure okay
i'll forego that even though i'm gonna
die i'm gonna wrestle he's gotta wrestle
him right extensive good luck with that
he's gonna get he's gonna get how's he
gonna he's gonna get lit up if he tries
to stand with him so he's left with one
thing that's not true it's wrestling now
can he keep him on the ground
or is this guy that strong
oh you think uh you think size and
strength yes is enough to just get up
from anybody i think that's a high level
to shara there's not enough hours in the
baby there's not enough hours in the day
and i think in two years he's two years
an hour so hold on hold on so you think
in two years he can make up the ground
that whitaker's been doing since a kid i
think what he can do is is get to a
point where he whitaker has trouble
keeping him on the ground and whitaker's
got to ultimately stand and bang with
him and now when whitaker's battle stand
up no where are you going you can't
stand with him well he can't go tip for
tat form but with mma you got to realize
whitaker's footwork in that taekwondo
footwork sure
it's not kickboxing i understand but
that's not going to help him with i know
what's going on i know it's going to
happen what you drink kool-aid you know
what this oh hey can we get some more
casual kool-aid i don't know don't say
casual uh another round of applause
casual kool-aid don't say it around for
casual i do
liability it might be wrestling a
hundred percent so there are guys that
are gonna grab them by the legs and
bring them to the ground now he's gonna
pick up the top seven guys not named
dizzy can all wrestle not named izzy and
sean strickland all of them can grapple
and wrestle bring up all the guys bring
up all the guys from what yeah
middleweight right the
i'm doing 3000 3000 things right now
yeah
um unfortunately pereira is going to be
he'll stay the champ and i think uh i i
admit that wrestling might be
a hole in his game
but
you got to close distance and you're
assuming he doesn't have a lot of
wrestling experience after two years
with glover maybe zero wrestling
experience no he's got training doesn't
count he's got two years
that doesn't so marvin vittori it's not
going to happen for him oh no hold on
hold on b b marvin matory can wrestle
he can wrestle yeah he can rise and
wrestle but he don't get
what
all that all that
happened what about this stand up about
derek brunson
again all he's got to do
is be able to stand up against bronze
because so many guys can do that
there are guys that when you're that
tall
there it's a lot easier to do oh that
makes sense just the way he is technique
yeah because
he hasn't had that much how much
wrestling has he had
all the rest he was a kick boxer for a
long one hold on but how long has he
been training mma i don't know how long
has he been training way long five years
five years oh dude no wait longer than
that way long in pierre so all he's done
is that anti-wrestling now izzy ain't
taking pierre down no but compared to
pierre izzy's [__] chrome gracie on
the ground um i don't know about that
you know i i i think that at the end of
the day when you're that athletic that
tall that strong i think it's easier to
keep people from putting you on the
ground
and easier
ten years so b so you're saying as long
as you're athletic and strong
you can get up
and stand up against the highest level
guys in the world well you you know
that's not right well you know it's not
right right you know that's not right
because then uh pujanowski would be
undefeated right he could beat everybody
in the world he's the strongest guy in
the world strongest man yes strongest
guy ever yes i i'm gonna say now tim
kennedy could hold him down well i could
hold him down
because there's a thing that we call in
the biz technique right sure he goes a
long way well nobody he's not a stranger
he's glover to share is a hell of a
wrestler think about who's glover to
share has taken down and held down that
has nothing everybody has nothing to do
with pierre but that's his heaven
hold on kevin holland went to ak to work
wrestle with khabib and dc sure
yeah it takes i i understand you're
working at a deficit
there's not enough hours in the day greg
hardy greg hardy sure way better athlete
than pierre all pro nfl sure all pro
lived at att yes you sucked the att boys
off right yeah he lived there i sucked
them up he lived there have you seen his
jiu-jitsu and grappling
now compared to pure athletically yeah
different [__] planets uh well i
you're a little bit anybody who plays
football you think is the greatest
athlete
no no no no no no no no no no not the
greatest athlete
ready all pro i understand starter ready
i just so you figure out starters sure
for the carolina panthers all pro sure
first
team i don't know 100 percent
yeah no i'm so it's not even like oh he
played some football right hold on i'm a
repeat again yeah
started
for the dallas cowboys have you ever
heard of him yes oh yeah now pierre
still a hell of an athlete looks like a
hell of an athlete to me and has proved
everybody let's say at the top of his
game in in in glory okay it's a big deal
yep right name one guy he's fine glory
go
i've watched some of his fights name one
guy i know i don't know okay besides oh
yeah sure name one guy he's beat in the
ufc besides sean strickland just give me
one well that's that's the big question
yep this is why you're casual i'm not
casual hold on b he's better better oh
you're not a striker than everybody in
that way he's playing no he's not gay or
not
really nate who's better striker is he
as far as mma goes he's a better striker
uh we're going to see about that we are
we're going to see about that because
look look at the thing is he beats him
yes you do 100
you wanna bet on it yeah five thousand
dollars okay
five five thousand dollars sure
guaranteed am i who's it where are we
even right now that's a lot of money or
even after the last campaign we're gonna
bet five thousand five thousand dollars
now hold on i love izzy i love izzy oh
no don't suck them off nothing
i'm i'm a fan of aziz but i'm gonna be
excited this is what i love this is what
i love about the mma community yeah
nobody besides the hardcore is where tom
pierra until he beat sean strickland so
everybody's familiar that's not what i'm
talking about
no i'm just saying this is how this is
the this is the the wavelength
he's a terrible match for izzy in terms
of striking that that we that that
that's what i wouldn't say terrible okay
have you watched their flight actually
watched the fight and he was getting the
best of him correct so he was actually
getting the best of him in his
particular strength which is stan and
izzy was actually actually is he had him
wobbled in his second fight
wobbled it was
not at all and then and then he caught
him with that shot and he knocked him
out anybody can get caught like that so
the smart money would be on the champion
on izzy people are saying is he's doomed
and stuff the smart money's uneasy
because he's a champion he'll find a way
to win but it's also the coolest thing
to say like oh pierre knocked out
straight
it's intriguing it's intriguing it's
intriguing i think it's very
short-sighted on the ufc i would vary
100 on that i agree 100 but we're gonna
i would also bet my entire year's salary
that derek brunson beats him really
awful matchup for him awful because
derek darrell closes distance and puts
him on on his back yes that's all he
does we're gonna have to see because i
think because pierre beats darren till
he beats uriah hall
and then after that there's nobody in
top 15 he gets by because of the
wrestling the red they're going to wear
him out and then and then have we seen
him in the later rounds how's he do in
the third round with his stand up well
when his arms are tired his legs are
tired he's getting dragged to the ground
we're going to have to see all i know
and here's the thing
you have no idea i know what izzy does
when you go and get stuff i see him
against kelvin die he's ready i'm
prepared to die i'll bet on that guy
there's no problem i bet on that guy the
new kid in town i'm not bad no you
always bet on israel out of sight he's a
champion for a reason and he hasn't
moved from that spot so in my opinion
people are confused because they go ah
he plays it safe you know against your
candidate yeah well all the fans i hate
that kind of talk that's the dumbest
[__] in the world i'm gonna take this
bet five g's i'm gonna take this bet and
and shake it i will five thousand
dollars five g's i'll get easy
what i'm taking izzy yeah and i got
[__] now i want to be very clear for
listeners brian is a fan of gavin newsom
and pierre yeah no that's what we've
covered today yeah dude you're a fan of
pierre check out my handouts
i'll let you pierre i'll let you that's
fine i get it yeah i get it yeah it's
gonna lose your fire it's fine it's fun
but newsome and it's gonna and it's
gonna bum you out and i'm gonna be
bombing news where i draw the line right
i understand but listen because you read
a book i understand saying how hard to
be governor now this is this this is an
exciting bet because the smart money
would be on israel out of sonia i know
that but here's what i think okay
a strong hand
your hand's strong bubba now here's what
i say
um it's gonna it's an exciting bet
because
um is etk i believe you're gonna be very
surprised at pierre's wrestling his
ability to stuff take down and stand
here's the thing everybody's gonna have
a problem you're not gonna get it you're
not gonna see that you're not gonna see
that
izzy's not gonna wrestle him
be a tko in the second or third round
you're not going to bang really is he
going to sit on the outside pick his
shots wait for pierre to come in and
knock him out just like you did whitaker
you don't think people see here's here's
why i think pierrot gets it done pierre
hits harder
sure
and that's a big problem because this
technique is high level so he hits
[__] hard and i think if if izzy
stands with pierra there's a chances he
picks him apart the promise pierre is a
very high level striker too and i think
that because he hits harder that's a
dangerous situation terrible matchup for
izzy or bad matchup or is he let's say
or let's say this and let's say this is
his biggest challenge right now right
now no but i'm saying a prime dude don't
get it twisted
prime hold on a prime whitaker is a
tougher matchup for izzy than pierre
pierra we know he's he's is he's camping
we know exactly what pierre is going to
do we know a 280 what he's got there's
no mystery there right whitaker can
wrestle yeah he can kick he's explosive
he has the knees
wherever it's going to go
wherever you want to go he can do it
wasn't enough against izzy kelvin gassim
we don't know he's going to double leg
him he can grind him out has the cardio
for days we don't know what he's going
to do is he beat all those guys yes he
does is he versus kelvin gaslum finish
top three
middleweight fights or fights for that
matter of all time yeah is he is he is a
very special
mma community has such a short memory
when it comes to stuff you forget what
got izzy to the party b i'm not saying
you i'm saying the fan base in general
forgets of course and everyone wants to
see the crown taken everyone see it i
don't i don't we bet five thousand
i'm just thinking i'm intrigued by this
i'm intrigued
i want to see you've got a guy who's a
high level striker at six foot four six
five who can who who
who is who hits so [__] hard and
accurately right so so now i'm going oh
he hits harder than izzy he's probably
got the same technique as is he right
different strikes different he has the
same technique has the same technique in
glory and kickbox yes now with his hands
down a relaxes against sean strickland
yeah again
fourth fifth round how does that go for
you yeah i'll tell you how that goes
because the defense isn't there is your
if you're now i don't think yes he's
gonna take him down i i he could i i
don't know i don't know this first time
izzy has the advantage grappling which
is insane first time ever yeah i don't
know if he wants to mix it up is it but
then again it says he can't like go this
cop out because we can't stand with them
right that's why it's intriguing i just
think it's very short side of the ufc
we've never seen this happen in the
history of the uc that's to go okay
izzy's beat everyone what are we gonna
do this guy
who can't beat it that there's a reason
why jump the line let's see him there's
a reason why he doesn't there's a reason
why they might jump the line that's i
would like to see him give us one bad
man get past that get us excited get as
excited i've never seen anybody fast
track why would they do that why don't
they build it up
because it's a risk because if you he's
gonna lose to a good grappler he's i
promise you that they want a high-level
guy they want to have fireworks
hermanton mops the floor with them so
they want to have fireworks
do you need more meat like izzy's the
t-rex in jurass park where they toss the
goat in he's destroying everybody yes
they're like we need to mix something up
here dude so pure there's a ba there's a
story line there there's no rest for the
king but to me it's so short-sighted
let's say he and there's a chance let's
say he beats izzy what do we do now bad
well then you got a rematch right and
then you have the trilogy fight so what
about the rest of contenders they're
just chilling there because this guy was
an interesting storyline well english
that's your champion the risk is that
you have the most colorful marketable
star in the ufc and if cara starches him
if he gets him because he hits hard and
he's really high and then he hits him
again that can ruin a career but how
long do you think about how long do you
protect pierre for this is the next
matchup guarantee your eye hulk because
we know they won't wrestle yeah how long
do we protect them for
how long are we just going to protect
pierre and for what because he's not
marketable no not at all yeah you
already have a problem with the russians
yeah that's going to be that so what do
you you know i just feel like it's so
short-sighted yeah i also think if and i
do think this happens i think izzy beats
pierre there's nothing for him right and
if luke rocco destroys paulo casa
there's a narrative there because luke
former champ you could do that would
luke fight at 85 or is he going to fight
at uh 205.85 really yeah that's a [__]
to suck down for him no no no no no no
yeah i thought he was fighting 205 no no
but by the way this kid is just a
[__]
scary looking rock
my lord
is clever
just sean search but bisping said it
best you know he called it early on he's
like dude i've trained with you he can't
wrestle everyone keeps saying he's gonna
take me he has a good job and then
that's it yeah so he landed a few jabs
but eventually everybody ties him up in
practice
i think that what he did is that's why
he went to glover and said teach me how
to wrestle
you know sure and i don't know who his
training partners are i don't know who
other what the other wrestlers are is he
in a really good wrestling camp in
connecticut
i don't know going with glover you know
he's pretty glover's pretty [__]
talented at wrestling you're saying
bisping said strickland or straight
yeah he was like can't wrestle oh i
didn't know he's like everyone says he's
gonna shoot down he goes he can't
wrestle he's not a wrestler at all yeah
oh
he likes to scrap he's gonna scrap
gonna get he's gonna lose
he's been called because he's training
with matt ruka yeah he's like i'm
telling you he has a good jab he's gonna
land a few jabs and then he's not gonna
shoot because he can't wrestle everyone
keeps saying he's gonna wrestle he can't
[__] wrestle yeah he's jiu jitsu guy
who strickland how much you know
primarily
should be or 365.
it i mean it's fun to talk about with
izzy and this guy now that's fun that's
what that's what uc did it yep
i'm excited
you have five g's on it dude five g's
yeah do you wanna bet i don't wanna i
don't wanna do you wanna bet ten g's
that newsome doesn't win the president
election
absolutely
did you guys see the ad he released in
florida sure did yeah no what was the
app yeah that's why i talked about going
against desantis going we have freedom
in california hey floridians if you want
to come here how blind can you be
like how's the economy doing dude is it
a troll tactic it's pretty okay so
here's an important thing about the
economy and okay so everybody just when
they they talk about a surplus they talk
about a surplus okay in in california
because all these companies in silicon
valley are going public so there's a 95
billion dollar tax
like um
uh
that goes 95 billion dollars in taxes
are going to the state because of
silicon valley
no one has been more [__] um hostile
to big tech and to san francisco that
created all that wealth than the newsome
administration and all of the [__]
far left people in sacramento so guess
what all of tech did they left yes so
you're huge all the money you made off
those all all those companies airbnb all
those companies that started in
california in that 21 mile radius some
of the most innovative people on the
planet uber [__] airbnb
you name it oh i don't know google you
ever heard of google nope yeah
all these companies that changed the
facebook
world okay let we can just keep going
everything you use that all your tech
started in a time it was just a good old
boys network it was just a bunch of
dudes nerdy dudes who were sitting there
in a room and they they all wanted to
make money and they changed the [__]
world because there was an incentive to
make money and everybody was like if i
have a good idea i'll make a billion
dollars and they all [__] did now
they all went public this year remember
though
you got guys like elon musk who are up
there paypal all that [__] was all that
ecosystem they all worked competing
against each other sharing ideas it was
one of the most incredible times bill
gates microsoft even though that was in
washington but it was all within that
ecosystem
it all started in [__] it all started
in san francisco silicon valley and so
there was no there hasn't been that kind
of a hotbed of innovation that changed
the world in so long yes it was all
white it was all straight males i know
they're all terrible i don't care who it
is but who gives a [__] i don't care who
it is the best idea it's just the best
ideas it was just happened to have been
it could be transgender
i don't give a [__] it was just it just
happened to have been a group of people
that changed the [__] world's
smartest [__] and gave so much tax
revenue to california right they've all
left and they all have because you have
a congresswoman in [__] california
who says [__] elon musk that's what she
said she's she's in congress she goes
[__] elon musk so elon musk goes really
you guys just want to make my life
impossible i'm going to leave
san francisco and this was just an
article written by a liberal reporter
who is a who is a lesbian woman okay and
she she goes
these these far progressive
anti-business people have killed one of
the greatest [__] cities in america
and it's called san francisco and you
think it's a dead [__] town anything
most touches turns to [__] so one thing
trump got right so don't you know it's
it's not about we all we're all for
equality we're all for not being
prejudice all that [__] but you don't
know what the [__] you're talking about
yeah how's that going for you guys
unbelievable man and just [__] do you
want to take the bet or no with newsome
uh because you seem pretty high on that
the point is 10 g point is vote for news
from guys
let me pee i get peace oh man okay all
right we're back let's see what we got
dude what do you got chin court events
you got man i'll tell you what i got
fort wayne indiana next week next
thursday friday saturday fort wayne
indiana then the following weekend i
have some special guests at the lab
factory san diego heart of san diego
and then we also have a shop and friends
on the july 21st i'm the late show now
because so goddamn hot out it's shopping
friends uh july 20th that's a wednesday
then san diego july 21st to the 23rd
baltimore the trash panda summer tour
continues in baltimore august 4-6 just
added chicago doing a theater out there
one night only friday night chicago den
theater because on the 27th is the thick
mudder the tough mudder can come running
with your boy at 10 am use promo code
thick boy for 10 off come run with your
boy it's the thick boys versus the
buttery bros and they're limiting their
because we had over 500 people sign up
last time that's too many because i
can't run with all you guys and people
are complaining so they're going to
limit the amount of sign ups for the
thick mudder on the 27th in chicago so
hurry up and sign up right now at
toughmutter.com well jason brennan uh
i'm going to be in the milwaukee improv
july 21 22-23 i'm shooting the best of i
need to find something to shoot in
milwaukee i need if anybody's from
milwaukee hit me up and let me know what
the [__] i can do in milwaukee
go on the uh jeffrey dahmer tour i could
go on the jeffrey dahmer tour i could go
on the jeffrey dahmer tour serial
killers i need something i've got to
make money from the exciting things
where my dad my dad's from milwaukee so
jeffrey dahmer born and raised but i
need if you're from milwaukee hit me up
with that with ideas i'm gonna be there
with my camera crew we're shooting the
best of dropping uh sammy the bull i got
a two-parter with sammy the bull and the
[__] i did with him when he was in town
it was a lot of fun we captured some
really cool stuff i got uh
i got some other stuff so oh dan
crenshaw and i had a long interview i'm
going to release the entire interview
but you can see pieces of it where i
talk to him about who who he thinks he
could beat in a fight interesting in uh
in congress and that was a very
interesting answer so anyway we had a
blast so best of the in austin and then
i'm in austin cap city's july 28 29 30.
and by the way little rumor cap city's
very special guest may be showing up
very special guest a certain comic who
lives in austin
brodogan i'm just saying
a guy who opens for me you've heard of
austin texas cap cities b move your seat
just a little forward
too he's a friend of mine and he's
showing up he's very special guest he
might be bald might be a little shorter
than i am i might not be vaccinated you
never know either way i hear there's a
very special i never have donald trump
on his podcast i'm just saying there's a
very special guest
cap cities and austin texas get your
[__] tickets now then i got nashville
tennessee zany's august 26 27 you know
who i'm putting up on stage
i'm saying it first
will compton from busting with the boys
they've done shows before doing stand-up
so i'm going to put my boy up yeah
they've done the shows at zadie's before
get them up on stage uh and we'll have a
blast i think i'm doing busting with the
boys so that'll be fun i'm gonna go hawk
hunting i'm shooting that [__] uh on and
some other things i i'd like to come up
with a i want to write i want to find a
studio and find a good musician and
write a theme song for best of i want to
personally write it with a good musician
and come up with something fun do it
with brows maybe
is he in that chin oh you want to do it
in nashville yeah oh i don't know about
that we'll figure it out no brows is
here maybe jelly uh spokane washington
spaghetti comedy club september 22nd
23rd 24th i'll see you soon all right
jim what do you got all right hold on a
second here we go
okay so this is my good friend jasmine
brown she's dating cam newton and i'm
not mad at her
she's uh super she was on 50 cent with
me and she's a
really funny santa comedian oh you've
talked about her before yeah
just to be oh i've seen her destroy
theaters yeah what
opening for like like following dc young
fly actually um
what's up what's she saying here though
she's she was in this podcast and was
basically like
listen go ahead you know like packing
his bag
unpacking his bag what's being
submissive just making sure all the
things that he wants and i i pretty much
read his mind so it's like i know you
and i study you like i know how you are
in the morning i know how you are about
midday i know when you're in this mood
what you need like before you can ever
ask me for something i'm already on it
damn i mean
what a woman and you know when i talked
to my girlfriends about it i was like oh
how are you guys doing i'm just like
girl he's rotten i'm like he's spoiled
rotten like he's rotten but i love that
like i want him to be there i think my
biggest flex is how i treat myself and
i've been known to love people back to
health was she the hottest girl of all
time god she's wait you gotta pause this
for a sec because i wanna just say they
did a poll in the uk which is a pretty
progressive part of the world
only seven percent of women identify as
feminists because
they're starting to realize it does it's
just if you get if you're a radical you
mean guys are unattractive
with your cat in your netflix account
and women like this like like when she
talks first of all she looks empowered
like i i got nothing but respect i will
worship her feet but she's talking about
spoiling her man and i'm literally like
i'm like well it goes both ways if you
do that then i want to see 100
yeah
i saw a very famous woman and a famous
guy and i watched her do the same thing
i was talking to them and they've been
very successful and she they're married
and she said oh i have his clothes late
now she's a makes a lot of money famous
she goes i have his clothes laid out i
know what he wants for breakfast and
with her whole schedule she still does
that for her man and i was like
[__] that's impressive yeah it
doesn't take away from her power you say
mark she oh just that she like because i
know her she's such a strong person and
isn't like she's no you cannot push over
yeah she's not like this isn't like i'm
weak it's like she's one of the fiercest
people i know as far as like she'll say
exactly what's that power there that's
ownership there her going no i want to
do this this is how i take care of my
brand so this is people like oh girl you
just no
a lot of controversy
because people hear that and go like oh
my god what he was made
[__] are lazy no that's because they
can't do it and she's attractive right
so i just i heard that and i was like
just knowing her and knowing what that
means and how selective she is and how
like high quality of a woman she is it's
like that means something a big time
yeah she doesn't have to do that no this
day and age girls don't have to do that
no now you're gonna be lonely with seven
cats your netflix count and your twitter
followers
so
how does that work pick your poison you
know
that's what's going on though like like
women are struggling
yeah
yeah anyone who's worth their salts like
oh this isn't going well i'm only as
[__] all i do is [__] wine nights
every [__] wednesday night there's
nothing wrong with it and playing
monopoly there's nothing wrong with
being dedicated to somebody you love and
your children
but either way whether it's a guy worse
than the girl the girl worships the guy
right both ways or a guy worship guy
girl worships girl i don't give a [__]
it's not a a passive or
oh what are you a housewife from the 50s
yeah that's cool man you mean helping me
out you know because i'm grinding my ass
i got my lady at home with my my five
five and a half month old you know what
kind of a full-time job that [__] is
yeah it's so [__] hard yeah there's
so much to do oh it's a full-time
keeping a house with a kid what
full-time gig full-time gig yeah
full-time [__] doing it well oh big
difference art form yeah yeah art form
what have you got jen here we go
yeah so i guess brad pitt
shocking he uh suffers from face
blindness it
occurs in one out of every what it's
like two point five percent of the
population blindness he can't remember
faces he can't recognize people by
looking at their faces even family
members i'm the opposite oh really no i
forget names but faces i'll never forget
a face shame like we're in ohio and i
kept seeing this guy i'm like god i know
him i couldn't put my finger out and
then finally he's like dude used to work
out at boxing burn like seven years ago
right like that's where we know yeah
i see a face i never forget it names
good luck dude
i can't tell you that [__] lawyer's
name i i have
skeptical hippo eyes here we don't
remember maybe you're just lazy no i i
think he knows so many people and so
many people introduce themselves your
brain can only i think what they say can
hold like three or six hundred names
various faces
so you mean you're just like the rest of
us
i mean oh you mean you're he's normal
this is his apologies like look all the
people whose names i've forgotten
because i'm brad pitt and you know also
hey i'm brad pitt i'm so famous and
everybody wants to suck me off so
everyone wants to suck it so i forget so
many names that's what i i feel like
what's going on is that's exactly right
he was like you know i'm just going to
say i have face blindness dude i'm gonna
run with that i'm so sorry i have face
blindness you don't remember me i'm so
sorry we can medicalize everything
that's that's kind of genius oh when if
you accumulate accuse me of being racist
i'm like
i have a condition
face blindness i don't see color i can't
tell everybody in my eyes is just a
general white color i i just i just see
flowers i just i just assume humans are
all white i just see flesh i see
flashlights it's a medical condition
it's a metallic condition dude i just
see
just kind of a vanilla look yeah no
matter who you are
it reminds me of chronic fatigue
syndrome because that's it's like a
similar topic like aren't you just lazy
though don't you just not want to do
stuff so yeah it's like fat people i
know it's a thyroid problem
what but i saw you eat two large pizzas
i know it's my thyroid
but
one of the two large pizzas i have to
eat your thyroid
yeah it makes me crave pizza
all right next one
ooh
hold on hayden panetta
when i first moved to la i had some
times with her you did not sexually she
was dating my best friend scotty
mcknight so i would go to her this is my
first experience in l.a l.a i would go
to the hollywood hill she had a house
there i was like holy [__] that's the
girl from [__] uh remember the titans
that's all i remember so hot she was so
hot and dude and such a boss like you
want to talk about like ownership and
like feminism beasty was just boss all
of us around
she'd like make sure you have my house
at eight because we're going to this
party or this club should come down at 9
30 just getting ready we didn't say [__]
you didn't see the show nobody had any
money it was all her [__]
so we'd be in our big ass house she's
coming out at 9 30 but yeah i guess
we're ready to go jump in the car beast
smart girl too but she had a problem
with alcohol and opioids
uh what'd she say natural star good
morning says she struggled with
substance abuse as was bout of
postpartum depression after having a
seven-year-old daughter i was on top of
the world and i ruined it
um
let's see i'll try to start all right
keep going uh it says happy pills no go
back go back
go back hold on for a second
at one point her addiction to alcohol
got so bad she was hospitalized
suffering from jaundice and the doc's
warned her liver was going to give out
whoa
that's no joke looks like they were
giving her maybe adderall or something
as a childhood star she says someone on
her team gave her happy pills before she
appeared on red carpets
yeah during interviews i had no idea
give her those happy pills
yeah this is horrible
um
but funny that you don't hear about like
because unless it's johnny depp or
something you know you're just kind of
like oh whatever happened to this person
it's like is that hayden there what's
going on there her boyfriend he's like a
terrible person
well she was married to uh klitschko
yeah but this guy i guess this guy
actually has domestic violence stuff
against he hit her or something like
that before she's still with her she's
going down there's hayden he's hitting
her last time we saw him she was in a
massive brawl with her boyfriend brian
back in march that she seems to be
better than ever
i see that because he caused this fight
apparently
[Music]
so there's hayden little hayden
that's him in the white eye zoom
hold on
a lot of pointing going on
how stupid is this stuff as a grown man
look at her now
oh she's a little spark plug bubba she
is a spark plug
punch in the face
why is she falling that's her boyfriend
oh she's following her yeah she wants
him to stop
because he's gonna go to jail
oh the guy ran in there okay he did a
flying kind of weird move hug clearly
nobody oh there she is
oh
it seems like a lot of guys wish those
two that's awesome this is all the whole
[__] everybody's lying down on it
sloppy hayden's like in a strong side
right side
oh she has her man in a headlock
i don't know what's happening
oh oh that girl is oh that girl's
beating hate in there
that's hating right now
boy this is
a bunch of hollywood [__] awesome
guys jeans are so skinny and that's
coming from a guy that's those are guys
holding on to each other
just lifting his legs
she's she's on top of him she's a little
spark plug oh
it's just sloppy
amazing this guy's getting pulled off
oh she tackled someone oh she's tough
she's drunk [__] by the way
because you know this is being filmed
but you're still doing it
no this guy's a boyfriend needs to get
another this guy is trapped he needs to
get knocked the [__] out
klitschko is going and you want our kid
around
us
when scotty was dating her uh that's
when she just got a relationship with
klitschko at the time
and scotty called me i never forget this
guy comes and goes dude i think there's
like this black suv follow me around man
because you know i'm hooking up with
hayden and she just broke up with
klitschko okay he goes yeah because she
left scotty went to glitch go they broke
up scotty came back in the picture and
he calls me goes dude dude i'm like
driving around there's this black you
talk escalades follow me i go okay he
goes dude it might be klitschko and his
boys go yeah dude you're hooking up with
this girl he goes i know what should i
do i don't know what do you want me to
do
i mean i feel like you could maybe
handle these guys go oh oh no absolutely
not dude i'm with klitschko on this what
are you doing dude that's his girl what
are you thinking man i'm gonna do
nothing right because they're russian
probably kgb one of the black guys
around klitschko they're not [__]
playing around
you're not fighting all those guys
no problem correct excuse me is a
disaster why are you calling me
i'm not batman
i'm not gonna fight russians for you
yeah i'm like giant russians i'm with
glitch matter of fact i just tweeted out
your [__] location i'm with him hey
you should be [__] talia vitali i get
it man
bro you believe this guy [__] dick
they play college football of them i did
but [__] him up
what else
cute little smart smart fast
beast receiver had all the records
handsome handsome play for the jazz and
made money play for the jets best
friends mark sanchez like they're like
brothers they grew up together girls
didn't like those two together at all
all right this is dj jazzy jeff talking
about will smith and it's kind of
hilarious oh he wouldn't did that to no
gangster oh he wouldn't it did let me
let you know something about will will
is somebody that cliff dove in jamaica
and couldn't swim
will was the person that
whatever he's afraid of he runs to i
ain't got that in me i don't have that
in me at all i've watched will almost
die
numerous of times running straight will
would have slapped mike tyson
it did not matter i think it was just
the perfect moment will would have got
his ass beat but he was going to do what
he was going to do regardless of i
believe that yeah i believe that i think
he finally got to a certain height
mike tyson i think he was like
he might not have went up to him and
slap him i guarantee he would have been
silent he would have started talking
[__]
maybe but a little more hesitant but i
do think there was just a moment of red
there and he would have slapped whoever
i i think there are times in your life
where you're
taking a beating is worth it it's beside
the point you're still going to fight
no i get that but i just don't think he
would slap my cousin ever yeah you're
not
all bitching
give us one more chill i gotta roll dude
um you wanna do this one mark
uh yes so looks like bam margera is back
in the news again
we talked about this a little bit before
we bailed on rehab
then uh
we have a video of him
he's in the yellow hoodie back there yes
those guys don't well it looks like he
has some good i know dude well they all
look like they're uh i'll tell you
they're in their 40s with face tattoos
yes i was going to say this what you
don't want to have happen if you get out
of rehab you don't want a video of your
man partying with a guy with face
tattoos
that's a red flag you don't think they
have it together these guys
but also be a good friend of bandit
don't [__] take around this stuff if
you care about that and then he's just
passed out right there and the bummer is
bam's a dad dude and his girl is a dime
piece that poor girl look at his friend
he's in shape at that age you're hanging
out with these guys
and they're doing this to you filming
you while you're out i just think that's
pretty much yeah look at him he's all
passed down they're filming that sucks
dude look at these that sucks man look
at those losers holy [__] that's bad
you can [__] off with your drugs and
alcohol but how do you not get sober for
your [__] kid baby because you're
caught in that whirlwind and you're also
hang out with these morons
here's a real quick one do you guys know
kyle farnsworth sure do picture
now for mlb yeah he's in bodybuilding
now yep whoa uh first of all all natural
let's see
how do you get the veins in your cat and
your shins that's got to be natural yeah
oh my god
those aren't those veins at all
now that's good so there's no blood clot
he has veins of a maple leaf so that's
cool
yeah yeah he was a pitcher you're a good
d good pitcher not like a superstar but
pitcher now do you think he did any pds
while he played mlb or do you think he
just dabbled when he retired crazy dude
come on stop my [__] tat is sick
though yeah
that's it yeah so there you go so yeah
he can be he he was doing competition
too yeah the boys jack city good for him
man exactly yeah sort of good for him i
don't know something to do you get done
i feel like there's a blood clot in
those [__] shins just do we
daddy that's why the veins are light
yes
is that from like what kind of protein
shakes is that just like
way isolate and then you gotta name a
steroid dude
hey namaste i can't talk about that but
also so when you take anabolics too your
red blood cell counts increase so like
you have more blood pumping through your
veins your blood gets thick you can't
talk about the stuff there's still yeah
yeah you're right in theory well that's
the end but your blood will get thick
and that's why i see a lot of people on
a ton of
gear i had a buddy do it he did so much
like his neck was red and his face was
yeah because the blood's so thick it
gets so bad they have to drain some of
your blood because it's so thick yeah
you can get stick like a milkshake heart
attack all day all day yeah so is that
it mark that's it that's it mark great
the boys are back
boys are back baby boys are back if you
haven't uh seen it yet we got the pod it
dropped last week probably when you guys
are on vacation with sammy the bull the
number one muscle for the john gotti for
the john gotti the underboss the
underboss um and then we also just
dropped on monday it's jelly roll it was
a very late podcast
we did on what tuesday night he b-lined
over here from doing jimmy kimmel we
[__] love jelly roll um sweetie and i
love fort wayne indiana i will be there
next thursday friday saturday july 14th
through the 16th fort wayne indiana get
your tickets right now then [__] are
selling out it's the start of the trash
panda summer tour it's a whole new hour
come get some los angeles hollywood
improv july 20th that's a wednesday
night one show only at 10 p.m shop and
friends some monster comics you have a
very special guest for that night then
san diego heart of san diego laugh
factory downtown san diego july 21st to
the 23rd
baltimore august 4th through the 6th and
then chicago just got added one night
once only at the den theater in downtown
chicago because the 27th is the tough
mudder the thick mudder we are limiting
the amount of sign up so make sure you
go sign up it's the 10 am race you'll
have it on there's the thick uh mudder
you'll see all the boys on there the
thick boy squad is coming to chicago
we're doing comedy on the 26th get your
tickets now appleton wisconsin september
8th through the 10th and there's a bunch
of other dates on there sickboy.org yeah
thinkboy.com or t or fatkz.com
love you guys uh brookfield wisconsin
milwaukee improv let's go july 21 22 23
hit me up i need to make milwaukee
exciting i got to shoot some stuff
that's going to make it a good best of i
got austin texas cap cities july 28 29
30 with a very special guest
showing up to open for me you might have
heard of him but i'm not going to say
what he is but he is a comic who lives
in austin hinton
nashville tennessee zany's august 26 27.
uh i'm gonna be doing some [__] there
too and then i got spokane washington's
spokane comedy club september 22 23 24.
come get some
that's it kids love you this the fire
kid we're out